okay thanks everyone for coming
so the format of this is going to be all
the idea of a thing of this tutorial is
going to be that people can sort of get
their hands a bit dirty and play with
things so there's not going to be much
terms in the form of lecture there's
gonna be a few basic concepts that's
we're gonna look at and there's going to
be problems that the people that you can
solve and it's really encouraged to try
and solve them so we'll give like a few
minutes per problem and then just walk
through a solution so yeah and we'll
sort of work our way towards actually
training in a tab yeah a nice and
interesting network okay so the first
thing is there's a notebook that you can
get we can get this talk from from this
location maybe it's a small one see that
is that okay so these are the problems
basically so it's like a problem
notebook
and we are we're gonna walk around this
wall annoyed and also if you have
problems and questions during West once
the problems we're doing the problems
you can put your hand up and one of us
can try help you maybe a mitre needs to
come I don't know if he can help us
okay so I think everyone has got the
thinner book not yes oh yeah sorry yeah
yeah yeah no it's a connection okay yeah
wish which is how are using
okay well it's actually not it's not a
hundred percent necessary that you have
that you have the Internet yeah
so unfortunately yeah you'll have to
yeah there's a problem at the end that
you were quite internet for and
hopefully it's working within okay
so first before getting to the first set
of problems the first set of problems
are gonna be about layers so I don't
know how many of you guys were the talk
this morning okay
so some of you okay fine so so layers
are the basic constructs in neural
networks and neural networks are
composed of many of layers so we're
gonna get some understanding of what
these layers are so for the simplest
layer one of the simplest layers is dot
plus B this one has some weights and
biases which can be gotten via netic
stripes but if you don't have if you
haven't initialize the thing else then
if you turn net extract it's it will
just say there's nothing it's automatic
so once you've initialized it we can
look at the weights again and there's
some random weights now and we can try
to initialize it again and it won't
change the weights
unless there's a setting that you can
put to force the weights to be
reinitialized
and obviously yeah there's good
documentation for each of these things
so if you get stuck on something okay so
that's basically yeah like there's a
layer or even even simpler one it's just
like 10h and these layers once they you
know once they've wants you to find the
weights and everything you can apply
these layers to to actual data so for
example
[Music]
so the element-wise layer is going to
apply the function inside so hyperbolic
tangent to all the entries in the vector
no matter how yeah so it doesn't like
the dimension does not have to be
specified okay yeah so this guy if you
can play with us as well you can say has
the element was layer and you can just
apply this data and this is actually for
this simple example it's exactly the
same as just applying ten h4 to the data
so you might wonder what is what is the
difference between a layer and just 10h
so the answer is there's a few things so
one is that layers they have they know
about shape inference so they know like
if I give it a certain tensor size so
for example in this case okay for 10h
it's pretty easy if I say the input size
is 3 a vector of size 3 or let's say a
matrix of 3 by 4 it knows to infer that
the outputs is also that size the second
thing is every network layer is
differentiable so if obviously 10 H is
also differentiable was just D of 10 H
of X but for other kinds of operations
like convolution or pooling or all kinds
of things like this it's not obvious how
you differentiate those things with
symbolically and in fact a lot of those
don't have symbolic internet different
derivatives so an even though for this
case it's like a layers is very similar
to just yeah the normal function and in
the general case it's not just like that
and the other thing is that these these
layers they can operate on GPU or CPU as
well whilst 10h in the system doesn't do
that no
that is bizarre I don't know why that is
happening okay well I have to switch a
computer if this is keeping doing this
okay so there's a whole bunch of layers
in the system and we're gonna have a
look at a few of them so here are a few
problems so the way we're gonna do this
is that you can start with one for
example this one here and try and solve
the problem and then in a few minutes
time I'll explain how I would do this so
yeah so the first one use the replace
layer below to initialize it check it oh
it's right yeah so so basically this
question is this guy this dot plus layer
I can create a boss plus layer
initializers and I can obviously apply
this data so dot P and this thing takes
an input of size three and returns
output to five so the question is so
here's a formula for four how this what
this layer is doing so the question is
try replicate this layer in more firm
language so with matrix multiplication
and whatnot and this will give you some
idea of what the top level what it's
actually doing
yeah
you can look at the documentation but
like you can get connected extra layer
comma weight or layer come up by it
you shouldn't use 11.1 so the beta
builds is not working properly for
neural networks yeah so the back end
yeah there's all kinds of reasons but if
you have to yeah use 11.0
okay so this one is very simple so this
one is so yeah so here's but I mean this
book this guy yeah okay so that's what
we expect to get out
so the question is yeah what is this
what is this actually doing well it's
pretty simple we say dot plus always
there net extract see how that coffee
paste is the problem okay I don't know
what's going on this build
that is a bit troublesome
okay so basically the stringless we're
gonna apply this to a vector let's say
one two three we get some results and
then we want to say what is this
equivalent to well we say net extract of
dot plus layer and the weights and this
is some weight matrix if this gets
daughter's matrix multiplication with
the inputs and we add this with the
biases and that gives the same thing so
this layer this is the sort of
foundational layer for neural networks
and it's as simple as that
okay the next layer we shape it up so
this layer so there's a bunch of layers
like reshape layer and various things
like concatenation
there are basically purely tense
operations that allow you to massage the
data into the correct form yes so
actually in this case yeah if you look
at oh I copied that happies okay
sorry we're gonna change computers
because this is something is
I put this on 50 yeah that's funny okay
and there's one or two things that also
a potentially useful like when you're
creating the layer itself you're able to
who want to you can say you know the
biases in this case something like this
so you can set the parameters in the
beginning if you want okay so there's a
bunch of other layers like reshape layer
flatten layer that allow you to muss to
change the dimensions of the tensor or
to do operations on them like that so
for example flatten layer is often used
so dot plus layer it requires if you see
what the type signature is it says it
wants a vector but what happens if you
don't have a vector suppose you've got a
convolutional network or something where
you've got a multi-dimensional tensor
you can then apply fat layer to make it
into a into a vector so yeah so so
basically the quick exercise is to see
how this relates to array reshape for
example or flatten in Mathematica so the
question is actually listen let's even
do something like this so how would you
replicate this behavior for example with
sir that's not reshape yeah so how would
you do this with a Raver shape basically
so try create this layer apply it to
some data and see what's try replicate
thus with with Wolfram language and then
the same thing with flatten layer and in
fact the flat layer what I want is this
flat of
actually the nest was even more so yeah
how would you do this in orphan language
do I present that
de-stress
yeah
this is pretty simple so reshape so this
this basically takes a tensor and you
can see if you click for this it takes
an input and the output is of that size
two by two so for example this guy here
so this is just the same as like array
reshape Mathematica and this will be two
by two
also you might notice something about
the layers that these are always even if
I if I put integers in it will
reinterpret them as floats so the
outputs always gonna be floats and the
reason for this is that yeah that
everything inside the network is a float
and so it's it gets really recasted to
that okay flatten layer obviously this
sort of thing that's just equivalent to
flatten but there's a subtlety here
which is that flatten okay so the
flatten sorry so the one subtlety is
that it's flattened to infinity this the
flat layer okay but it's just in this
case flattened okay and the last one
then is an example of a different kind
of layer which is a lost layer so the
key to training the networks is to be
able to compare the output of a network
to to the true result so there's a bear
called mean squared last layer and this
guy if we look at the signature what's
going here
okay well let's switch so basically this
guy takes in an inputs and a targets and
it computes the how different they are
and the way that it does that is it
subtracts these two vectors it squares
them and that's us so
you can just try and verify quickly for
yourself that's that operation does is
the same as this and then also get some
intuition about what's what exactly that
means like what does it know it looks
for those specific keys it has to be
water exactly and the reason is yes so
all the layers they have what are called
ports so even like reshape layer the
ports are inputs and outputs so if
there's a single if there's a single
argument to the function so if the
function of malaya has a single input
then there's the the easy syntax which
is you know you can just apply it as a
function like that however the general
syntax is obviously an association where
you explicitly state that yeah the input
port is like us
oh sure I see so if the target vector is
nine and ten how do you use that number
okay so okay so so this guy what is it
doing so I can actually go down more
okay yeah so so what this is doing is
very simple this function let's say f it
takes in the inputs subtracts the
targets it squares them or maybe I
didn't mention that you also have to add
them up so it adds up the differences in
the vector and it divides yes so
actually so you could just do mean of
that right okay and we can test that
this works you get a different result
can't see so this is actually just put
this data okay sorry so f of okay so
they're playing this function to the
data okay well that's the same okay so
this this guy yeah it's very very simple
it just looks at the mean of the squared
differences in the vector okay and this
is the sort of the standard thing so
like linear regression for example it
uses this sort of loss function okay so
that's that then the next sort of set of
layers that I want to talk about things
that operates on images well they're
designed to operate on images so there's
two main image layers that do this so
the first one is a pruning layer and
this actually there's a very nice demo
of this if the internet is working okay
okay fine so how can show that right not
really
Oh see so it's yeah was working
okay well you said get it done get up a
son okay
oh okay that's a good thing well gets up
has done is he is I kind of just sure
yeah
katella's are working okay sorry uh
which one was it okay so never minds
will continue with us why did it go
change but it's not the same that it was
on okay
so sorry so this has a parent has
illustration of how pooling and
convolution works sorry
so the way that this works is that so
pooling is okay I'll have to describe
quickly so pruning is very simple it
basically has a kernel that goes across
the image and that kernel does something
example there's max pooling which the
kernel just says okay what is the
maximum value of any pixel inside the
kernel and it takes that value as the
pixel value as the upper pixel value
there's other ones like average pooling
and various other ones and this this
thing it reduces spatial invariance so
if you have this in a network you can
prove that that you introduced spatial
invariance to translation so it means
that like for example if you're
classifying whether this is a sunflower
it means that the network is told that
it shouldn't care about if this images
on the side or the side or anything like
that so this is a very powerful powerful
layer so a quick thing to try is to see
is to create a pruning layer
and then apply it to the image and see
what's what it does and the hint that is
important to actually get something nice
so obviously layers one more comment
about layers is that they only take
tensors everything this is purely tensor
based so if you want to apply this to
something that's not a tensor then you
have to use net encoders so you
basically say the input goes to an S
encoder or for sample an image of size
what should we say like 255 or something
and this guy this nation coder gets
applied like if you apply this to an
image like in MJ sorry then you just get
a tenth out of the pixels and it does
all the resizing and conforming it and
all that sort of thing so the question
is yeah what is what is this - and the
pudding layer takes one parameter which
is the kernel size and you can either
give a kernel size that is the same in
both dimensions or you can say you know
for the heights and width you can give
different kernels so you can specify
that explicitly so the reason that you
want to do this nice and coda thing is
that's you wanna be able to give this an
image and then you want to also this
micronet decoder which can reinterpret
the outputs as an image so in this case
we're gonna do some ifs okay no sorry so
5 let's say oh sorry
I'm sorry what am i doing
I'll propose to us and we pretty what's
on us say that this is grayscale
sure so that left the kernel size of the
pooling so that window that goes across
the image is 5x5 and there's also this
is this other parameters like stride for
example there are optional parameters
and that tell you how far the window is
gonna move so normally it's one like it
moves one pixel wide one pixel but you
can eat yeah you can change those nice
it should have no choice I shouldn't
have messed initialize yeah try applies
to image
so if you see a man maybe don't sit here
about the image dimension of the second
one is less than the original one I
basically couldn't like all the 5x5
matrices have been compressed to a
single value and also it's blows the
image as well because it's yeah it's
making it it doesn't care so much about
the location anymore and you can change
the blurring obviously by you know how
much the kernel is so this is very blood
or we can even try a 50 by 50 I know
what that does so just play see what
what what this looks like
look at that and then there's also this
parameters like the strides which allow
you to see how much it will jump each
time so just get some intuition for what
this is doing is the idea of this
[Music]
yeah I know at this time this is a weird
thing okay so that's the pudding layer
so I hope you've had some chance to play
with it so it's kind of yeah
yes so it needs to know what size it
needs to decode it does
oh it needs to know like what is the
tens'up it gonna look like so if it's
not that size so this thing I mean it
should work if it's 255 255 yeah okay so
basically oh it should work just like
that yeah sorry so but what she was
doing was that's just making it the same
as the dimension of the input image but
you can yeah you can obviously specify
what this should be and if the image is
bigger than it'll just resizes for you
if this was 255 then the output is gonna
be 255 as well yeah and you can see well
not necessary the OP was not gonna be
255 it depends on the onion like the
stride and how big the kernel is
poor this guy yeah okay yeah so is it
are you asking to do what oh so this guy
hell yeah so that agrees with us sorry
this is very small hi yeah so this is if
the stride is too you can imagine that
there's gonna be far fewer pixels
because you skipping yeah so in this
case like the number of pixels will be
126 and the image will be 126 yeah okay
cool so that's the pooling and the
pooling almost always comes after
convolutions so a convolution is exactly
what you'd expect it to be it's again
this demo would be nice but basically
it's like the like the pooling where you
have a window that goes across the image
so it goes across the image when it gets
the end of the image it goes down one
line so it goes across the the width and
then it goes goes down the the height
and the convolution is different from
pooling in that the the kernel it gets
multiplied with each pixel that it
caught that is its added point and those
what it's being multiplied with that is
a Lance parameter so the kernel that
it's being involved with is learnt and
it wasn't means that those learnt
parameters are used to control across
the entire image which is kind of wait
cheering okay so that's that's what it
yeah so convolution is it's like a
normal image convolution except that
it's the parameters for the convolution
kernel or that and there's yeah there's
one or two other small differences
so the main difference is they just show
this cookie so the convolution area you
can specify how many upper channels the
image is gonna have so in convolutional
networks the the input image will
usually be of size you know three
channel image but then you can make the
convolution you can say one set of
filters or one set of of kernels that
we're going to play that is one channel
for the output and we can just have lots
of those banks of of kernels
so this 64 here is the number of banks
of kernels that you're gonna use and
then you can also specify the kernel
size like 3 by 3 or equivalent to that
which is 2 by 3 and this has the same
interpretation as pooling and it has all
the same sort of things like strides you
can put that a 2 etcetera cetera the
only thing that's different between this
and verb the pooling obviously is that
there's parameters that we learnt so the
question for years
try try apply the convolution layer with
random weights and also with custom
weights to to an image and the way to
specify the weights is just by weights
and then goes to something and try and
send what these weights mean so you
could put random rail you could provide
them integer whatever and then trying to
apply to the image and the same thing
applies like you use an input encoder
for images and decoder for images as
well mm-hmm it's not an important to set
the biases and it doesn't matter okay so
actually this is what that's good point
so it should probably three outputs
because you want to visualize it
afterwards because there were 64
channels well you could still visualize
its but it's a bit more complicated what
it means
yes exactly
[Music]
it's a time okay that's going in I get
maybe should good okay maybe should yeah
just hurry up on this these basic things
because a few other more interesting
things to get to okay fine so basically
if you just want to apply this to an
image you can say precisely this stuff
here just you know it's copy this and
you have to net initialize it to be able
to use it this is for the random weights
so that's nets okay and then we say just
apply this finish and we get out
something so this is not particularly
interesting this image and always he you
can try this again you get something
different and also yeah you can try
different sizes of kernel so obviously
the bigger the kernel is gonna be the
more sort of blood and crazy the image
is gonna guess okay fine it's yeah so
big yeah and it's pretty easy to if you
want to have your own weights you just
put weights and well yeah I mean you
just put weights and another argument
tale fine so yeah okay I just could he
described the earth okay so I'm gonna
spend like maybe like five minutes on
this and then get to the training but
basically layers by themselves are not
that interesting Liz yeah like you saw
like the convolution that it can't
really do that much interesting you know
it can it can find edges it can find
various things but otherwise yeah it's
very limited so what you want to do is
you want to put many layers into into a
container so we've got two different
kinds of containers and the Wolfram
language we've got net chain for simple
sequences of layers where yeah you just
have a chain of is and you will have
graph where you can you can consider
arbitrarily complicated networks so he's
yeah maybe just the first two things
might be interesting so a net graph is
basically just a net chin so this guy if
you want if we were to make this
internet graph it's pretty simple it's
just this and you have to then specify
the connectivity structure so net chain
allows you to avoid having to tell you
this thing what it is and the way that
this works is positionally so this is
element one this close to element 2 and
2 goes to 3 and this gives you a net
chain and a graph so that's exactly the
same both of these and you can always
click on things as well ok that I know
what's going on there your build is
weird okay but basically you can always
click on nodes of graphs and chains and
you can see what yeah yeah exactly so
that's the other syntax so there's two
syntaxes for this one is this and one is
association where you name the thing
like ramp one goes to that's and kind of
one-third and and depending on the
circumstance one can be nicer than the
other one and this guy then as it expect
it would just be like ramp one goes to
on one and con one goes to pool one so
exactly the same and also what's nice
about this also with the syntax is that
the names in the graph reflect the names
in the Association
that's a question
I generally prefer the dissociation
syntax almost always just because it's
clear to me like oh the ramp one the
first ramp goes to the first
conversation was positions also the
other thing is that if you adding layers
the positional thing just becomes a mess
so if you're trying to insert a layer
see what happens if I add another layer
here that is a nightmare so I prefer the
syntax almost wise okay so this is yeah
so the graphs it cases like this and you
can also create graphs that are slightly
more complicated structure so in this
case we have an element-wise layer that
feeds into another limit was layer and
then both of these feed into a catenate
layer which concatenates for the outputs
of both of these okay so maybe we should
not spend too much time on this one you
can do this a bit later so there's some
challenges here for constructing net
graphs that correspond to various
Wolfram language expressions okay cool
so those are the containers so the first
training example is this so we're gonna
try train network that it takes three
numbers and it just adds them so it
needs to learn how to add so the data
looks very simple it's just three
numbers that go to the output and these
are just these numbers totaled so this
is that one now okay so we in a write a
network that's that will learn how to
add a very very simple task
so should give it a few notes yeah we'll
give you like three minutes to try and
to try and write a network that can do
this or two minutes
oh the Sun there was some issue with so
the things that always wants tensors and
skaters were not well supported or
something maybe
this one
after we stopped Sabri
okay so I'm going to show you the
simplest Network possible for this sort
of task so the way the way you design a
network like this you say okay and what
is the output what is the input so the
input is just a vector and the output is
just a scalar or a single element vector
so in this case a net chain seems like a
reasonable thing to use so we say net
chain and the simplest possible network
in this case will just be 1 dot plus
layer and the up the size of the output
of the dot plus so the number here is
how how many outputs there are and our
case we put one output right so it looks
something like this in this case it's
predicting it's one outputs and we can
even specify what the input is suppose
we know what the input sizes the input
sizes of size three this is three data
points okay so this guy is taking in a
vector of size three and just returning
a set vector of size one so the way to
train this is very simple you just say
net train and we say net and then the
data and this data there's many
different data formats this can support
this is one of them okay so he has an
has a has a first example of where you
can go wrong with network training so
this guy says so so one thing that you
mentioned has that's like classifier
predicts things have been automated to
the point where you don't need to worry
about anything from your network case
it's not automated in that way so
sometimes it'll it'll say we had a
problem and in this case it says the net
diverged during training try specify a
lower learning rate and if you look at
the documentation from a train I get to
this
okay
sorry so if you go to the documentation
of that train then you see where initial
learning rate is this thing it's just a
parameter for the method options so
there's different optimizers there's
stochastic Korean descent and there's
atom and this initial learning rate is
is how much the gradient descent step in
the beginning will go and that it can be
difficult to decide what that's depth or
the correct step size should be a priori
so like for classify it would try all
kinds of different steps and what knives
in this case it won't it will you sort
of on your own so what you can do how do
you get back to the okay so one thing
you can try to do is when you have an
optimization faded like this so if the
learning rate is too big for example it
might it might lead the parameters to go
to too large values and then they become
nuns or something so one one approach is
that you just try different optimization
methods so for in this case we try a
atom which usually actually works better
than the stochastic or and descents
sure yeah so you can specify that
parameter and try a different initial
learning rate I can show you how to do
that as well okay cool
so this is the last the last curve so
this is telling a tower how close it's
getting to the true answers and through
go it's finished training exactly yeah
so Adam is an adaptive learning rates
method yeah I don't know why this
actually wasn't used at the defaults
I think we've changed this now so it
always uses this and stochastic grand
descent is that for people that want to
fiddle but at some point we had this
yeah there was some historical reason
why we decided on this so in this case
now
okay the network I should have actually
outputted that to do something but
actually three trainers you have to try
it again sorry
that's a exactly this is a bit of a
weird so let's try this two three four
let's see if that works yeah it looks
like it's trained mostly stop it and you
can always stop it as well and then it
takes for the best Network at that point
okay so this is yeah it's reasonable
yeah
yes exactly so I chose reals from zero
to a thousand so let's try it 200 150
and 250 so that's three hundred four
yeah that's pretty close by the way if
your first layer is doing I'm like you
know what the answer should be like it's
just some numbers there should be one
one one that's the weight matrix in this
case and maybe you can show how you get
the matrix now like we saw how to get
the matrix weight matrix from layers but
you can also get the weight matrix from
the network yeah so if you have a
network you can extract it's like I
thought so
it's and then fun at chains you can just
say I want the first the first guy so
what if the syntax is working here fine
so basically yeah so this is another
syntax will be but for the next version
but yeah you ned extract the layer and
then from a layer you just say extract
the weights okay
and these the weights so cool so this is
this is learn to to add and you can try
all kinds of other thing that's like
what about learning if it can learn to
just to multiply it or who knows what so
yeah
so this is the first sort of very basic
example of of how to train a network so
this one one sort of detail that we that
okay is one detail we sort of went over
that I glossed over and that is that net
trained you see this network there's no
loss function in this previously I
mentioned that there's a loss layer so
what happens with neck train is that if
it sees a network of a very of a basic
form like this it will see ok the output
that's just a normal number and we're
gonna attach the last layer
automatically however sometimes you
don't do that sometimes you want to
specify your own loss or you want to
have multiple losses so the next thing
is the next sort of challenge is what
happens if you want to train with two
different losses at the same time so as
you don't have much time I'll just maybe
just go through those how to do this but
basically now you've got a network
that's is gonna have many outputs it's
gonna two outputs because there's two
different loss functions and by the this
is this last function here is like mean
square absolute last except that it just
takes the absolute differences not the
square differences of the vectors so in
this case it becomes more complicated
also if you attach the last layer that
has another input port so your network
now has two inputs so net chain has not
gonna really work for that
so what you really want is you want to
neck drop so dot goes to plus layer so
we're going to have the same it's gonna
be a single outputs but that output
we're gonna feed into two different loss
functions so how do we do this well
there's one more concept that is
important maybe the last remaining
concept for this framework and that is
this there's a concept of a port as we
saw with example this this last layer
thing so the last layer is that put
these ports they're gonna input ports a
target ports and then the last port
which is the output so the question is
how how do you refer to those and the
answer is with net port so in this case
we're gonna say there's going to be
three inputs to this network there's
gonna be inputs that goes into the dot
layer and the corrector is specifying is
that this is gonna be well yeah this is
not gonna work so net ports of inputs
and this thing if we change the name of
this thing you'll see that's a different
name and if we if you feed this such a
data
you then have to Association the name
that you're gonna have to give it is
that that in there okay
so the input goes to that and we want to
have a lastly as well so this is plus
one goes to that's
so there's an input then there's a
target one which will go to nos so yeah
so here's here's exactly with us the
situation comes in so because it's net
port that's so how do you specify
because this layer in our so the last
this this mean squared last layer has
two different input ports so you need to
be able to specify which one you want to
attach you know the input of the network
into that one so this is where this is
where things become a little more
complicated so in this case is very
simple dorsal as well he just say net
port or plus one and this is the the
target and we also want to say that the
dot layer that are one layer or layer 3
that goes into last one but it goes into
the input port yeah so now we can see
input goes dots that goes into the the
correct input port of of the mass
function and then the first target goes
into that so now what about another loss
layer well we do the same thing we just
say let's say we're gonna use a mean
absolute loss this time so so we lost
two so there's now three layers and we
want to do the same thing with the dots
we want to end the sky so we just copy
this guy yeah so in this case this this
refers to the target to refers to the
input to the graph so there's a target
to from the graph that goes into the
second loss function into the target
port of the second loss function and
that goes into the input port of the
second loss function
BAM look at this so now this guy it
solves exactly the same problem but it
has two losses and now it will many
trainers it will try and minimize both
those lots of small taneous view
and we can try it and in this case now
also the general syntax of net trainer
is necessary oh yes sorry this should be
a name here yep - okay and then we say
also yeah this should probably have some
information of what how large the input
size is going to be so in this case the
input is 3 and you can see that all of
this sort of works out nicely and then
you're going to plug this into there and
the general syntax malla is what
actually weight these targets actually
the same because yeah there's only one
yeah that's right
that was stupid so sorry so this guy is
actually the same as that hey guys
that's better so the general format of
the data is that when a train is that
you say in this case there's one input
port called targets that goes to one
piece of data and there's inputs which
goes to a piece of data and what is that
well the data's of a form or was it was
that so basically the one of them is
gonna just be everything and then one
that's so so the input is that and this
guy is - and you can see that this this
syntax here allows you for any number of
ports of input ports for the network to
train that sort of network so let's call
this net 3
oh that's a good point
so basically net initialize you don't
need to do it a few if you're feeding in
a so net chain every internet train
sorry
so net train will initialize it if it's
not initialized net train will
initialize it for you but obviously if
you want to use this thing Ness
initialize you have to do that yourself
and like if I want to feed this into
some data now so it was on pole inputs
goes to exactly right okay so what that
means is okay and that message I think
here that needs to be improved so
basically what that message means it can
mean either this one initialized or it
doesn't have enough information to
initialize it so for example if I don't
specify that this input is of size three
then then it won't you can't put this
internet train cuz it needs to know what
what what's expecting so I think this
will give you the same error message
unless you stop okay so I think we've
run out of time
cool what's the time yeah okay cool so
sorry so we didn't actually finish all
the things that we want to do it through
but I hope you've got some taste for our
how to build these things up Shawn but
something has gone wrong there yes opers
that protective environs sorry yeah so
you know it was a plane last thing in
Italia but and just take off it so let's
see can't connect last place that I put
ok so what it's trying to do is it's
trying to interpret it and say that say
I finished same thing okay we have to
finish oh oh come here
ok ok cool
Provine there's no time for questions
but if you want to talk to us we'll be
standing around so
[Applause]